only on CBS this morning we are
revealing the winners of national
Geographics 2018 Travel Photographer of
the Year contest National Geographic
received more than 13,000 entries from
professional and amateur photographers
around the world the annual contest is
divided into three categories nature
cities and people the grand prize and
nature category winner is underwater
photographer Reiko takahashi wow look at
that
her photo is called mermaid and it shows
the tail of a humpback whale calf off
the Japanese coast a Swiss photographer
won the people category with this photo
capturing Mongolian hospitality titled
tea culture and this photo taken from
the inside of a tram in Nagasaki Japan
won the cities category the runners-up
include an aerial perspective of a
pyramid at this Mexican archeological
site these haitian twin sisters playing
in front of their home in Brazil and
flamingos taking off from a lake in
Tanzania you can see more of national
Geographics winning photos on our CBS
this morning Instagram page I always
loved that competition you see some
suitable things gorgeous